sion le principal problème au delà bien
sûr des pertes en vies humaines restent
les coupures d'électricité on peut dire
ce soir que des f est confronté à la
plus grande catastrophe de son histoire
elle a d'ailleurs demandé de l'aide
aujourd'hui à ses voisins européens près
de 3 millions de foyers sont privés de
courant sur l'ensemble du pays et la
situation ne devrait pas redevenir
normale avant plusieurs jours aux
explications de patrick esther et marie
emmanuelle guider une catastrophe sans
précédent 50 ans d'histoire pour
l'entreprise edf
des milliers de kilomètres de lignes à
haute et à très haute tension détruite
par le vent devenu fou pour la seconde
fois en 48 heures seulement le quart du
réseau hors service une véritable
paralysie pour ces autoroutes de
l'électricité
le réseau 400 mille volts est piloté
depuis ce dispatching national
implantée en banlieue parisienne une
installation que le président de la
république a tenu à visiter ce matin
devant les cartes le terrible constat
s'impose et saigner sont toutes ces
années c'est un comble son coût est de 8
à 9 millions français était alors privé
d'électricité
ce soir la situation s'est un peu
améliorée mais reste très tendue région
par région voici le nombre de foyers qui
devront s'éclairer à la bougie
l'ensemble du territoire est concerné
l'ouest et le sud ouest sont
particulièrement touchés et resteront
probablement dans le noir plusieurs
jours dans la journée nous avons réussi
à rétablir l'électricité dans cinq cent
mille foyers ce qui est
compte tenu des conditions météo
extrêmement
extrêmement je dirais efficace les
équipes d'edf travaillent 24 heures sur
douze mille employés 30 hélicoptères des
centaines d'engins spécialisés sont
mobilisés mais la tâche est tellement
démesuré que l'électricien français a dû
demander de l'aide à ses voisins
européens pour récupérer pylônes
transformateurs et groupes électrogènes